technology like never before is being
used to curtail freedom of speech around
the world
mal and spyware artificial intelligence
and social media have become the chosen
tools by governments to suppress dissent
khadija ismailova was a victim of the
spyware pegasus which was developed by
an israeli company she was detained for
over a year in her country as eva then i
saw the list of the numbers like 99
numbers from my phone book
were in that list so 99 people whom i
know
were in that list they've been affected
too
and those were those were not only
journalists and lawyers
those those were also
activists political activists
whose numbers i had
hundreds of people have gathered in the
uruguayan coastal city of punta de in an
effort to help find ways to protect
freedom of speech
this conference is hosted by unesco and
the theme of this conference is
journalism under digital siege which
shows the magnitude of the problem how
journalists are not only at risks in war
zones or conflict areas but also are
subject to online harassment and
surveillance and that's why hundreds of
journalists members of international
organizations and many others have
gathered here to try to prevent
technology from being used to persecute
free media
the war in ukraine and the unprecedented
number of journalists who have been
killed in mexico this year serve as a
stark reminder on world press freedom
day that journalists around the world
are facing an extraordinary level of
threats
andre vasunet has been in exile for a
year he was forced to flee belarus when
the government of alexander lukashenko
began a crackdown of civil society and
media there's over a thousand political
prisoners in jail
[Music]
there are lots of people who are in
prison who are not allowed to have
visitors while lawyers cannot even pass
them a letter and at the same time there
is a group who are not in prison but are
always afraid that the next morning they
can be arrested and can be imprisoned
finding solutions is a central part of
the event people like irene khan have
proposed a moratorium on the sale of
surveillance technology that's being
used by state and non-state actors
around the world what we in the united
nations are calling for is a moratorium
a ban a temporary ban
on any use
transfer sale of this kind of intrusive
electronic surveillance
and then use that time
of the ban
to
strengthen national laws to strengthen
international laws on trade and the
reason why we
want this moratorium put on is because
we know
journalists themselves have exposed
stories
about how
lives are being threatened
individual lives are being destroyed
journalists are trying to adapt to
surveillance and digital attacks for
everyone here awareness and finding a
legal framework is crucial to defend
free press there is